their journey to space was only meant to
be five years they wound up flying
around
for seven hundred where did that much
food come from
you don't just magically produce seven
centuries of food on thin air
cupcake in a cup what's that what is it
people
they're eating each other it's the only
explanation
cupcake in a cup is people wally is
about
cannibalism oh there's more
hello internet welcome to film theory
and to our special three-way crossover
event
cannibalism week yeah that is not a joke
three episodes three entirely separate
but connected discussions on eating the
flesh of your own species
why because we can and when you've been
doing this for 10 years your content
tends to lead you to some strange
places speaking of 10 years on youtube
we just celebrated that anniversary over
on game theory but it's got me to look
back on some of my favorite early
theories across all the different
channels and
a few really stand out here on film
theory the seinfeld one about how
envelopes can kill you an
underappreciated classic in my opinion i
mean who could have guessed that youtube
audiences wouldn't be super hyped about
that spicy seinfeld content am i right
there was also that time where we taught
leonardo dicaprio how to win an oscar
you're welcome for that one leo still
waiting for you to acknowledge my
existence that 50 shades of grey episode
where i showed how the romantic love
interest uses the same psychological
techniques that cults use to break down
their victims
super demonetized but also super fun but
of them all
one still stands out it's one of the
all-time most viewed videos on the
channel
number 11 just barely missing cracking
into that top 10
wall-e feast of flesh back from a
different era of youtube when you can
get away with putting severed human arms
into thumbnails the theory is all about
the food situation in my favorite pixar
movie wall-e pointing out that in the
film we see humanity herded onto giant
spaceships owned by the megacorps by and
large they were originally planned to
provide a five-year getaway vacation to
humanity while robots cleaned up the
garbage fire that was earth but as it
turned out things were polluted beyond
repair
turning that five-year getaway into a
700-year multi-generational voyage
hey there auto pilots got some bad news
operation cleanup has well uh
failed rather than try and fix this
problem it'll just be
easier for everyone to remain in space
okay i'm giving override
directive a113 go to full autopilot
take control of everything and do not
return to earth
my original theory took those facts and
ran with them a five-year vacation
stretched into a 700-year voyage means
that there are 695 years worth of food
unaccounted for
that's going to be a problem because the
starliner that our story takes place on
the axiom
seemingly has no renewable source of
food given the fact that people on board
are unfamiliar with the basic concept of
plant where's the thingy plant right
right
where is it oh sure we hear briefly that
the ship has a regenerative food buffet
regenerative food buffet unchanged but
that system is also run
entirely by the autopilot a computer
that's adhering to directive
a113 as we just heard it means taking
control of
everything to ensure that humans do not
return to planet earth even if plant
life is found
so how do you regenerate food when there
seems to be no other source well you do
it using people
after all a centuries-long journey with
hundreds of thousands of passengers
means that a lot of people are kicking
the bucket along the way
and when presented with the problem of
what to do with all those human cadavers
the robots who run everything can kill
two birds with one stone
dispose of the bodies while feeding the
remaining guests
after all everyone on the starliner
consumes everything through a straw add
enough artificial flavoring and who's
gonna know the difference
but since that video's released four
years ago you've asked a lot of
questions
down in the comments and i've realized a
few things that i missed in that
original theory so today we're getting a
little bit meta call it a film
theory theory going back into the
archives and updating an old theory by
filling in a few holes and answering
some of the questions you've left along
the way
ladies and gentlemen it's more daytime
leave your theories in the comments
below
i'll pick my favorites in the next
episode of morty
okay first things first evidence points
i missed after going back through the
movie and all its associated media i
noticed two key details that really
hammer this conspiracy home
the first is that there are no old
people on the axiom
none there's two guys who are balding
with gray hair but they
don't look old in fact if you scan
across the character models that we see
whizzing by in the movie not
one is wrinkled elderly slow or frail
they all have smooth skin
and nice hair even if that hair is gray
and mind you
this isn't just a selective sample of a
few dozen characters we see
hundreds of axiom passengers over the
course of this movie
you'd think that at least one or two of
them would be elderly in some way but no
none nada it's almost as though the ship
disposes of those individuals who get
advanced in their age
so that's suspicious detail number one
number two though flies directly in the
face of that replenishing food buffet
that i mentioned earlier when we joined
the axiom in year 700 of the flight
everything is served blended up in a cup
there is no solid food which sure okay
might be some sort of replenishing
nutrition beverage that they've always
had
except we have proof that that isn't the
case
looking at some of the bonus video clips
released alongside the movie we see that
axiom
started by serving solid food in this
promo video to get humans to join the
axiom voyage we see that the ship
used to serve solid meats odd to
transition away from that policy if food
really is replenishable automatically we
also know that there's no organic food
waste on the ship throughout the film we
explore all the various garbage shoots
present on board and we see that it's
all composed of mechanical waste
metals parts old robots no peels rinds
old unused food
dead bodies nothing just saying that the
replenishing food story is uh
shaky at best now in the comments a lot
of people were asking about oxygen fugal
mr cool murphy
hussein ahmed and more with many saying
that the fact that the humans are still
breathing oxygen must
mean that there's plants on boards and
then presumably farms
well actually that's not true for one
thing as i pointed out earlier no one
has ever seen a plant before so it seems
unlikely that there'd be a section of
the ship actively growing plants but
more importantly supplying enough
oxygen for a single human requires a lot
of plants on average it takes the
equivalent of about eight trees to
satisfy the oxygen needs of an adult
human which would mean that if the b
l starliners were making oxygen the
old-fashioned way they'd need to have
more plants on board than humans more to
the point though the how to get oxygen
in space thing isn't something we have
to speculate about because it's a
problem that's actually been solved by
real world scientists the international
space station has been in orbit for over
20 years and there are seven people
living there now all of whom are
breathing just fine without having to
bring 50 plus trees with them
on the international space station
oxygen is created using electrolysis
a chemical process that involves using
electricity to split water you know how
water's chemical formula is h2o
that o in there is actually very
breathable oxygen
in the previous video i already
established that the axiom would have no
trouble harvesting water from asteroids
and electricity is also a solved problem
thanks to solar power so the presence of
oxygen on board doesn't actually prove
anything in this case
that said there is one massive
correction that i have to make from that
previous video whether cannibalism does
in fact solve the axiom's food problem
can
man survive on man alone in general
a human cadaver is good for around 80
000 calories something that i brought up
in that first episode
more recent studies though have been
done since i uploaded that original
video uh
clearly i was the one who put
cannibalism research back on the
scientific communities map so you're
welcome guys
these more recent studies estimate that
the number is now closer to 125
800 calories but regardless of which
number it is it still leaves us with a
huge
problem it's nowhere close to what a
human needs to eat in order to
survive to adulthood if an average
person is eating 2 000 calories per day
it means that a single human cadaver is
only good for about 63 days worth of
meals
barely over two months of food it would
take a minimum
of 309 cadavers to provide a lifetime's
worth of sustenance and mind you that's
for an
80-year lifespan the dates that we see
for previous captains suggest that
people might be living for as long as
200 years
at that rate the axiom starting crew of
six hundred thousand people would only
feed a population of one thousand
five hundred and eleven that seems to
really bust the cannibalism theory well
the population on board the ship would
most certainly be going down generation
after generation
there's no way it could be going down
that fast
so is the theory busted well i'm not
quite done
you see while i was wrong in that
original theory to not take into account
whether human bodies could sustain the
population i was
also wrong about the calories that those
human bodies would be providing
sure a human is worth 125 800 calories
but that's an
average 145 pound or 66 kilogram person
the people that we see on board the
axiom are just a wee
bit heavier they're barely able to walk
currently the world record holder for
the heaviest human is a man named juan
pedro franco who weighed in at take a
guess
seriously i want you to take a guess at
this one because everyone i've asked so
far starts at around like 700 pounds or
317 kilograms take that and double it
at his heaviest juan pedro was 1
300 pounds 590 kilograms now obviously
the passengers on the axiom aren't that
heavy but the reason i bring it up here
is that juan pedro
as part of his efforts to get healthier
lost over 700 pounds
managing to slim down to a weight of 570
or 260 kilos which was where he was able
to regain
his ability to walk as such i'm going to
use that weight for our axiom guests who
are also
just barely able to walk so knowing that
the other thing that we have to factor
in here is that
fat has more caloric density than muscle
in fact fat is the most caloric food
source that's the entire point of fat
it's your body storing up energy for the
future
a pound of meat is good for about 650
calories
a pound of body fat contains closer to
that's five times as many calories this
means that a single axiom passenger
suddenly goes from providing over 100
000 calories to a whopping
3.85 million calories at the time that
they get ground up into a human smoothie
add to that the sedentary lifestyle of
everyone on board and you drop the
number of calories
that the passengers need per day from
2000 to something closer to 1400.
ironically the fact that the axiom
passengers have such a high body fat to
muscle ratio both makes them more
efficient as a source of food and also
reduces
their need for food it's a win-win
across the board i guess suddenly a
single axiom passenger goes from needing
to consume nearly 400 people to survive
for one lifetime to
only having to eat nine and that
shockingly enough seems very reasonable
i mean once you've eaten your first
human the rest go down easy consider
this last episode i mentioned that
during the course of the 700 year
journey the axiom has had
at minimum two million dead bodies six
hundred thousand people all living life
spans of about 150 years turned them
into food
and that's enough to feed over 222
000 humans for a lifetime and if you're
an autopilot program meant to keep as
much of the population alive in space
for as long as possible
that seems like a pretty darn efficient
use of your available resources
so there you have it friends i still
stand by this one between all the
evidence during our first go-around and
all the new additions here including the
surprising lack of elderly people on
board and the shockingly efficient food
source that human fat provides
i have yet to really see anything
disproving this one
you know what they say human meat can't
be beat but hey
that's just a theory a cannibalism
theory one of three all released today
so make sure you check out the other two
episodes in this buffet of flesh
and speaking of hungering for the flesh
of your fellow man
a special thank you to our sponsor for
today's episode the appropriately
thematic
state of survival how's that for a
segway a free to play zombie survival
game available right now in both the
apple and google app stores
stranded in the aftermath of a deadly
apocalypse brought on by a corporate
conspiracy you're forced to rebuild your
home
fight against the rampaging hordes and
eventually save all of humankind between
now and october state of survival is
crossing over with one of my all-time
favorite franchises the walking dead to
amp the zombie killing up to the next
level as part of the crossover there are
daily quizzes on
all things walking dead in state of
survival which promise both in-game and
real-world rewards including amazon
gifty cards you can also go
easter egg hunting where walking dead
references are hidden in every corner of
the game world collect them and fill out
your book there's even a special
appearance by the guy who made crossbows
cool again
daryl start saving humanity today by
downloading state of survival for
free right below this video and the
first 50 to download the game will get a
amc gift card no joke 50 for just
testing out the game plus
one lucky winner will get a nintendo
switch thrown in for good measure
all of it for downloading a free game
and if you're not one of those first 50
or heck even if you are
use the code tftsos that's um the film
theorists
state of survival to redeem a massive
in-game starter pack when you first
download it so there you have it friends
flesh-filled fun for everyone for free
so download state of survival and start
saving humanity today cause as wally
proves the robots aren't gonna do it for
us but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and
cuts